[Music]
all right brand new information this
hour from Sarah Carter who will join us
in a minute she's reporting that the
house Intel committee chair Devin Nunez
is now asking former top obama
administration officials for answers
about how much the former president knew
about the clinton bought and paid for
dossier and when he found out about it
now this is the dossier that was filled
with russian government lies of course
clinton used it to try and influence and
manipulate the minds of the American
people this is the one the FBI relied
heavily on to get that FISA warrant to
spy on the Trump campaign associate
Carter page during an election year now
Sarah Carter's reporting that
congressman Nunez he has sent letters to
many unnamed former senior Obama
officials in an attempt to find out the
extent of their knowledge about the
phony dossier we have been saying on
this program for months now that we want
to know what former Obama officials like
John Brennan James clapper Susan Rice
the new queen of unmasking Samantha
power and Ben Rhodes and President Obama
what they knew when they knew it and
Sarah Carter has also obtained a list of
questions that the Chairman chairman
Nunez wants answers to here are the most
partner ones we'll put them on the
screen when and how did you first become
aware of any of the information
contained in the steel dossier
now congressional investigations have
uncovered that the Obama FBI DOJ and
even the State Department of Obama all
either were given the dossier or were
told about what was in the dossier so
the number of people potentially
involved is vast and it is widespread
now the next question who did you share
this information with when in in what
form please describe each and every
instance and remember before President
Obama left office
remember he amended that executive order
one to triple three that made it easier
to share information across 17
government intelligence agencies by the
way he never worked under this this
executive water the next question when
did you first learn or come to believe
that the steel dossier was funded by the
Democratic National Committee and the
Clinton campaign Hillary in the DNC of
course Donna Brazile told us she was
controlling the money at the DNC
they paid over what 12 million dollars
for these Russian lies government lies
propaganda to propagandize the American
people influence the election another
question asking when did you first
become aware that the steel dossier was
used to obtain a FISA order on Carter
page now we now know from two Republican
memos that the dossier to spy on Carter
page Trump associate was first granted
in October of 2016 before the election
it was renewed three times afterwards
and yet people like James Comey Andrew
McCabe Sally Yates Rod Rosenstein oh we
can't forget lisa page and her mistress
and his boyfriend and then of course
dana Bente now we also know that that
mccabe testified without the dossier
that application for that buys a warrant
never would have been approved and
speaking of the application remember in
the Grassley Graham memo the bulk of
that FISA warrant application relied on
the garbage this dossier had in it that
fusion GPS and the FBI never verified
now that's even more troubling because
under oath remember James Comey he said
it was salacious he said it was
unverified and he also briefed them
president-elect Trump about the fake
news dossier and that was in January
2017 and he said the same thing to
Donald Trump he said it was unbarring
but months earlier in October Comey had
no problem using it to get the FISA
warrant to surveil Carter page now on to
the next question this is very important
was President Obama briefed on any
information contained in the dossier
prior to January 5th 2017 now we know
about January 5th and that meeting
because the former national security
adviser remember Susan Rice she's the
one that sent her email to herself on
president Trump's inauguration day and
on the way out of the White House Rice's
describing a meeting from January 5th 15
days prior when she and then Vice
President Joe Biden James Comey the
Deputy Attorney General Sally Yates
herself and the president were all in
this meeting she stressed all Barack
Obama wanted everything with the Russian
investigation to
done by the book he wanted it by the
book he did not instigate this
investigation he wanted it by the book
sounds like a cya and why would rice and
an email on her way out of the White
House sounds like she's trying to cover
herself and President Obama her attorney
of course is saying that the email was
not unusual at all really
you believe that now newness is also
asking those Obama officials if they had
any contact with members of the media
about this dossier and we learned that
the former British spy Christopher
Steele he was briefing outlets like the
New York Times The Washington Post Yahoo
News fake news CNN all about the dossier
all before the election and Nunez is now
giving these officials until March the
second to reply by the way we did reach
out to former President Obama for coming
shockingly they never got back to us so
in addition to finding out what Obama
knew when he knew it when it comes to
the dossier we're now asking the same
questions about the Russian election
interference
now the Muller indictment clearly lays
out that this Russian interference
campaign started in 2014 Donald Trump
wasn't running and we now know despite
warnings back in 2014 from people like
congressman Devin Nunez President Obama
did nothing now we're calling it a
dereliction of duty especially when you
consider what Obama said just a couple
of weeks before the election lecturing
Donald Trump to stop whining take a look
I have never seen in my lifetime
or in modern political history any
presidential candidate trying to
discredit the elections and the election
process before votes have even taken
place it's unprecedented it happens to
be based on no facts there is no serious
person out there who would suggest
somehow that you could even you could
even rigged America's elections there's
no evidence that that has happened in
the past or that there are instances in
which that will happen this time and so
I divide mr. Trump to stop whinin and go
try to make his case to get votes how
about you stop whining no serious
president would have ignored the
warnings in 2014 they would have known
that Russia was a hostile nation with a
hostile actor named Vladimir Putin
remember never again remember tell
Vladimir that I'll have more flexibility
after the election it's time for
President Obama you got to start telling
the American people what you knew when
you knew it on the dossier and
especially we want to find out what the
former president knew when did he know
that Hillary Clinton the DNC paid for
these Russian lies and did he know that
the dossier was used to spy on a member
of the Trump campaign in an election
year and by the way on the issue of
election interference why didn't bomb ax
act is it because he thought Hillary
Clinton was gonna win and he didn't care
why he bothered anyway the president has
been slamming Obama on Twitter President
Trump that is for his response to not
responding to the Russian election
interference here's the president
president Trump's recent tweet on this
topic I have been much tougher on Russia
than Obama just looked at all the facts
total fake news and White House press
secretary Sarah Sanders schools the
media today on how President Trump has
been much tougher on Russia than Obama a
liberal media I know you don't do any
work you may want to play pay close
attention maybe learn something take a
look if Russia or anybody else
is trying to interfere with our
elections I think it's a horrible thing
and I want to get to the bottom of it
and I want to make sure it will never
ever happen now the thing I have to
mention is that Barack Obama when he was
president found out about this he was
told in early August by presumably the
CIA that Russia was trying to get
involved or meddling pretty strongly
with the election he did nothing about
it
the reason is he thought Hillary was
going to win and also we can't let
anybody play around with our voters on
our voter system but I have to tell you
this so forth now we're getting more
examples of how Obama failed over and
over again when it comes to Russia we'll
have that later in the show this
includes of course uranium one that
includes allowing Vladimir Putin to
wrestle control of 20% of our uranium
when it's in short supply why would any
administration let a hostile foreign
actor ever do that to this country and
we've also been telling you about how it
all started in 2009 you have a Putin led
Russian operatives right here in
American soil
they begin operating his self they
wanted a foothold in America's uranium
market remember we've been telling you
about this FBI informant Douglas
Campbell well he was there the entire
time documenting uncovering everything
bribery extortion kickbacks money
laundering and they did nothing how is
that possible now also tonight the
Special Counsel Robert Muller announces
a new plea deal with a lawyer tied to
Paul Manafort and Rick gates now the
lawyer accepted this plea deal for lying
quote to the FBI again oh no collusion
and included the legal documents in its
some very interesting information by the
way and Muller outlines how the lawyer
deleted oh that sounds familiar and
didn't hand over emails that have been
requested by the special counsel Wow I
was Robert Muller now setting a legal
standard is he setting a precedent can
we now go back and get Hillary Clinton
she deleted she acid-wash he bleached
bit and she beat the crap out of
divisive with a hammer
now Muller thinks that what this lawyer
did was wrong and illegal then maybe she
should take a cold hard look at the
33,000
males that were subpoenaed that she
erased then acid wash then bleach bit
and that had a rage beat up with a
hammer I think that's a good start and
by the way her team gave the FBI cell
phones we got to give him credit oh the
only problem is they didn't have any SIM
cards in them which basically rendered
them useless
so if Muller does care even a little bit
about the equal application under the
law equal justice under the law while
he'd be investigating Hillary Clinton
for destroying evidence in an FBI
investigation and that could be just the
start of Clinton's legal troubles we
told you last night about an article
written by a lawyer Robert Barnes for
the website law and crime here's the
headline does Muller's indictment when
you read it mean Clinton's campaign can
be indicted herself for Christopher
Steele this is a fascinating article
because Barnes is pointing out that
since Robert Muller indicted Russian
trolls in part for failing to register
as foreign agents and for not reporting
their activities to the FEC well not in
the indictment it is in the overall text
if you actually read the indictment well
does that create a legal standard from
Muller to go after Christopher Steele
Fuzion GPS the law firm Perkins cuy the
DNC and Hillary Clinton herself now
here's the legal reason why Steele he's
also a foreign citizen he was paid by
fusion GPS we haven't seen that steal
ever registered as a foreign agent or
that Steele reported to the Federal
Election Commission's what he was being
paid so if we're going to go off this
precedent set by the Russia indictment
all the conditions are there in this
case robert muller should be
investigating steal clinton fusion gps
Perkins Cooley the DNC and Hillary
Clinton isn't about fairness and equal
application of the law if Muller's going
after Russian trolls then maybe he'd be
okay with prosecuting Steele and the
people paying him to create a phony
dossier full of Russian lies that they
tried to use to lie to the American
people now rush limbaugh hit an amazing
point on his radio show yesterday about
why Muller only indicted the Russians
for certain crimes he nails it this is
brilliant take a look the things these
Russians were charged with in the Muller
and
our wire fraud defrauding the United
States mail fraud these charges that the
Russians were hit with in this
indictment have nothing to do with the
avowed purpose of the Special Counsel
investigation literally nothing to do
with it and if these Russians were
charged the way everybody thought
charges were gonna happen then they
couldn't charge Hilary and they couldn't
charge
Christopher steel and Fuzion GPS but
they can't be charged just just because
the Russians have been because the
charges are different that's why they
didn't go after the FEC issues that's
why they didn't go after the the farc
issue what Russia is saying here is
brilliant it's that Muller may have been
shielding Hillary Clinton by limiting
the charges announced against the
Russian trolls because all of that could
have been applied to fusion GPS Hillary
Clinton the campaign Perkins cuy and the
rest of them brilliant point so Muller
again Hillary Clinton how does she get
everybody to protect her she's it's
always rigged in her case finally
tonight we have more damning information
about Muller's top partisan attack dog
Andrew Weissman take a look at the
headline LA Times is getting on board
finally doing some reporting in the
media Muller deputy Andrew Weissman has
a reputation for hard charging tactics
and sometimes going too far then the LA
Times details how Weissman has very
close ties to the Special Counsel Robert
Muller which includes serving as his FBI
general counsel for two years maybe this
will explain why Muller decided to tap
Weissman as his lead prosecutor even
though Weissman has the most atrocious
record of any lawyer that I've ever seen
in my life we've told you how he's bias
the political partisan hack how he's
donated thousands of the Democrats
including Obama and aside from
Weissman's clear and obvious political
bias what about his track record as a
prosecutor Sarah Carter last Friday
broke the story about how in a 1997 case
Weissman was officially reprimanded by a
judge for withholding extol Ettore
evidence
not the first time in the end Weissman
got bailed out by his powerful friend
and his name was retroactive Lee removed
from the complaint that's just the tip
of the iceberg when it comes to Weissman
and as part of the Enron scandal
remember Weissman's aggressive tactics
it caused the accounting firm Andersen
accounting to go out of business
it costs tens of thousands of jobs
people lost their jobs
Weissman secured a very controversial
obstruction of justice conviction
against Andersen that was overturned by
the Supreme Court unanimously ro he put
four Merrill executives in jail for a
year those convictions also overturned
by the Fifth Circuit Court of Appeals
and the LA Times is reporting as part of
the Enron prosecution Weissman named 114
people as unindicted co-conspirators now
why is that important because defense
lawyers argued that by threatening these
114 people with prosecution
Wiseman was able to block testimony that
could have helped their clients so in
other words Weissman was once again
basically withholding exculpatory
evidence it's hard to even fathom how
anybody is corrupt in crooked as Wiseman
can ever be considered to be part of
Muller Special Counsel team he has so
many red flags yet Muller took him on he
is his pit bull and that alone order
basically raised questions about
Muller's judgment but then again most of
Muller's team is filled with Democratic
donors so maybe that's what Muller was
going for all along here with reaction